It's like a balls and there's another
funny promo. He's sitting there,
that Guy Post Malone, right? And
I was sitting there with Nia gone.
That's the fucking guy I saw. That's
the guy that murdered that song,
those two songs. Right. So um,
he was talking about
con conspiracy theory.
I don't even know what
the commercial was about.
It was just him talking to
another guy. I'm telling you,
it's very like early days of MTV.
He was just talking about
conspiracy theory and uh,
being able to teleport and he was
just going like say here's area 51,
right? Which of course he picks that
rather than saying San Diego, okay.
He goes, here's area 51
right here. Here's Australia.
If you want to fly from
area 51 to Australia,
you've got to fly all the way here.
You know, and he draws the art too.
We just didn't draw a straight line. Like
someone actually understands aviation.
Right? Cause this is what creeped me out.
Cause if he just drew a straight line
and be like, all right, this guy's,
this guy's out of his mind. But the
second he drew the arc, I'm like, Oh fuck,
I'm buying into this theory. Right?
And he goes, um, and he goes, well,
with teleportation,
they just do stuff like this and he just
takes the paper and the x where area 51
was in the x, y Australia's. He just
takes the paper and he just folds it.
He pushes him together. He
goes, it's like that. He goes,
I know you guys think I'm out of my
mind, but I know this shit is true.
I like the government and conspiracies
and aliens open your eyes. Cheapo.
There's a lot of this going
on. How about the JFK shooting?
There's teleportation. Here's area
51. Right? And here's Australia.
In order to get there,
you'd have to fly there.
But if you take the piece of paper and
go like that and touch them right there
in the middle, that's how they do it.
And I know I sound crazy, but I'm not.
And I was like, this guy's brain.
That's what my brain tells me. You know.
So I, I don't know anything about
any of his, uh, and he was, uh,
any of his music,
but I'm definitely gonna wanna download
some of his shit if anybody knows what
his best album is or whatever,
you know, a good, uh,
jump off point for that guy. Um, it
would be, it would be, uh, be tremendous.
Um, so anyways, oh, by the way,
Navarro fucking killed the
guitar solo in that too.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].